from the way Democrats are talking about
Republican reforms to Obamacare you'd
think the party of Lincoln was going
house-to-house murdering people Hillary
Clinton tweeted that if Republicans pass
this bill there's a death party
these cuts are blood money people will
die Elizabeth Warren called the
Republican health care bill blood money
that's being used to pay for tax cuts
with American lives in reality the GOP
isn't even coming close to following
through on its promise to repeal and
replace Obamacare if it did it might
actually save lives increase quality and
bring prices down the plans put forth by
House and Senate Republicans which are
supported by President Donald Trump keep
in place the worst elements of the
Affordable Care Act this is the closest
we will ever get to repealing and
replacing Obamacare the House bill for
instance replaces Obamacare subsidies
with refundable tax credits meaning the
government would still pay people to buy
insurance though wouldn't require people
to get insured it does impose a penalty
for dropping coverage that amounts to
the same thing the Senate built in the
words of reasons Peter Sudirman is just
Obamacare but less of it the bill that
they have created is Obamacare but and
Donald Trump's words mean it's a
dysfunctional version of Obamacare that
basically says we don't have a theory of
our own we just don't like this and so
we're going to do less of it like the
House bill it requires that insurers
accept all applicants regardless of
pre-existing conditions and limits their
ability to charge more for sicker
patients the real problem with both
bills is that they don't challenge
Obamacare central premise which is the
idea that the federal government should
micromanage medical insurance markets
you were a schemer you had plans and
look where that got you
neither bill would increase the supply
of health care by relaxing licensing
requirements or getting rid of state
laws that allow existing hospitals to
bar new entrants into the market these
rules are one reason health care
facilities tend to stay open no matter
how poorly they serve their patients
neither bill would challenge the tax
codes that encourage us to buy insurance
for even routine health care costs
meaning patients don't even see the
bills for routine procedures like throat
cultures and blood tests until providers
are forced to compete on cost the market
forces that bring down prices and raise
quality and every other sector will
remain stillborn the GOP bills represent
not just a failure of nerve but a
failure of vision to implement policies
that might just deliver 21st century
healthcare for us all
[Music]
you